it I am not predisposed to optimism my
default is not gratitude nor necessarily
even positivity and so I have over the
years developed a couple strategies for
combating this and dealing with this and
you know the first thing is to just
accept it to kind of be angry that
you're feeling that way is only making
it worse and enhances the level of
suffering that you're experiencing I
also think it's important to always
remind myself that like cynicism is kind
of a lazy reaction to things I think it
takes a lot more gumption and courage to
be optimistic and have a positive
outlook and then from there
you know I try to engage in practices
that lead to or cultivate more optimism
positivity and gratitude in my life and
they all Trace back to this idea of mood
follows action this Mantra right if you
want to shift your mental or emotional
disposition you have to do something to
accomplish that